If you, If you just take
Tony's as a case study for a moment,
what is it that faith
does in these circumstances? We analyze it as opposed to just accept
what he's done.
And, actually Saint Paul is a very good example of this. In fact, to use
from a different religion
the Prophet Mohammed is very good example of this
the first thing is
you've got to
be prepared
to believe that something
that's wrong can be changed into something that's right.
You know, a lot of people look at the world, they don't dispute there's terrible things but they
just say, you know,
but actually what faith
does is it
gives you a
in a sense that
things can be
changed.
They don't have to be like that.
They can be changed. There's a sense of possibility that comes with it.
The second thing I think that comes with it is a willingness to think differently
and anew
and to challenge conventional wisdom.
I mean, I think what's interesting about all
the, all
the great
prophets -
and that's taken in the broadest sense certainly with the Abrahamic faiths -
but all the great prophets have one thing in common,
which is absolutely fascinating in the sense that now there's a, there's a kind of doctrine
about them
and that is they were all challenging conventional thinking.
You know, Saint Paul absolutely to radically, obviously, but not just
in relation to
Judaism and Christianity, but actually in relation to the practices of
Judaism, some of which were kept, but some of which were altered.
Saint Peter and Cornelius likewise. So there's that as well,
but again you could go
across the
religious movements and you look at any of the great teachers,
you look at any of the great teachers
with, for example, Hindu religion,
they're all people who are challenging
the conventional wisdom.
And I think the third thing is that it gives you is a determination to keep going
in the face of adversity and, and
to recognize that
there is something more important than the transient good opinion
of any particular time.
And that is what
I think.
Faith, faith
can only mean something if at certain
vital moment,
for all your weaknesses
and
limitations,
you are prepared to surrender self.
That's why, that's what
Islam, Islam means; it means surrender to God.
Right, so, it's, it's a, it's a, that, that is
that is a concept that I think is dramatically important in faith
and so what leads
him to do something that would be very: A)
that is thinking that he can actually change something,
when most people have said "Well, how
you going to get them to change that?" B) he does it
in certain circumstances where he's prepared to do something radically different and challenge conventional
wisdom.
So he keeps at it.
Now I think those are, those are really important aspects in the, in the way that faith can
interact with
the way that you, you, you do things and that's
and that's what you notice.
And, it's what you notice. I mean I'm a, I am a, a,
you know many ways, as a, as a practicing politician,
you know, when you're in government,
you're taking decisions the whole time, right.
And let's be honest about it, some of these decisions you're taking on a very
practical transactional basis, right.
And we go this way rather than that way. Let's suss it out.
We got
these problems that, you know, that is the business of politics and it's there,
but there are always crucial moments
in which,
actually it's not transactional issue,
it can be either a transformational issue or it's certainly an issue of great principle and it's
at that point
that you, you work out within yourself
whether you're prepared
to surrender what might be actually a short-term personal self-interest to something bigger.
So, when Tony decides, you know, they may describe as a
nut case and finish him off
but he nonetheless decides to do it. Now
the really difficult thing is if they had finished you off. Where would you be now? But actually
the fact is you would still be doing the same thing.
Now that's, that's what it gives you and that's the difference, I think.